[MUSIC PLAYING]
JORDAN HYATT: Good afternoon,
welcome to "Talks at Google."
My name is Jordan Hyatt, from
the Google Automotive team,
and I'm thrilled
to have Heartbeat--
[CHEERING]
--opera here with us today.
This is the first
time we've ever
hosted an opera
troupe at Google NYC,
and we're very excited about it.
My partner and fellow
Googler, Peter Dolchin, and I
were introduced to Heartbeat
just a few years ago.
And even though we're not
necessarily opera fans,
we were blown away by the
Heartbeat Opera team's
creativity and
passionate approach
to bring opera to a whole
new generation of people.
Please give a warm welcome
to the co-music director
Dan Schlosberg and
soprano Kelly Griffin
for the first performance,
an aria from "Tosca."
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - KELLY GRIFFIN, ARIA
FROM "TOSCA"]
[APPLAUSE]
JACOB ASHWORTH: Hello, everyone.
My name is Jacob Ashworth.
I am the other co-music
director, with Dan.
And I wanted to introduce you
to our next singer, Samarie
Alicea, who will be doing
a number from Rossini's
"The Barber of Seville."
This is where Rosina has heard
her lover outside the window.
And she hears his
voice and she knows
that she is going to be
able to make him hers.
I will make you
mine and I am going
to be perfectly obedient, no
worries-- gentle, absolutely.
She's a total firecracker.
And if anybody is
going to cross her,
they will find out that she
can also be quite a viper.
[MUSIC - SAMARIE ALICEA, FROM
"THE BARBER OF SEVILLE"]
[APPLAUSE]
PETER DOLCHIN: Hi, everyone.
I'm Peter Dolchin.
While we set up
the chairs, we're
going to take you
through a video of one
of the performances that
they had a couple of months
ago in Brooklyn.
It's a drag, festive
performance, so enjoy.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Ladies and gentlemen,
and fabulous folk
who transcend the
gender binary, please
rise for her royal majesty,
Regina Moana, the Virgin Queen,
Elizabeth I.
[APPLAUSE]
- Hit it, boys.
[OPERATIC MUSIC]
[MUSIC - "TONIGHT"]
[MUSIC - "BRUSH UP YOUR
SHAKESPEARE"]
[APPLAUSE]
[END PLAYBACK]
PETER DOLCHIN: Thank you.
So I'm Peter Dolchin from
the Global Partnerships team.
Thank you again for taking
the time to come out
and experience and learn
more about Heartbeat Opera.
The talent onstage
and behind the scenes
are extremely impressive.
They dedicate so much
time, effort, and energy
to this movement.
And I'm really excited for us to
learn more about who they are,
how they've chosen this art--
many may say that
it's chosen them--
and what it's like to
produce and perform
in this more unconventional
and emerging genre?
So with that, I'd
like to introduce--
or have you
introduce yourselves.
Please state your
name and what you
do for Heartbeat Opera,
and anything else
you want to briefly share.
LOUISA PROSKE: Yeah,
hi, I'm Louisa Proske.
I'm the co-founder and
co-artistic director
of Heartbeat Opera.
And I'm also a freelance
director of opera and theater.
ETHAN HEARD: My
name's Ethan Heard.
I'm a co-founder and co-artistic
director of Heartbeat Opera.
And I wanted to compliment
Peter on his beautiful shirt.
PETER DOLCHIN: Yours as well.
[LAUGHTER]
JENNIFER NEWMAN: Hi,
I'm Jennifer Newman.
I'm the producing director
of Heartbeat Opera.
And I guess I'm a
freelance producer also,
in theater and live arts.
JACOB ASHWORTH: I am
Jacob Ashworth, as you've
met Dan and me before.
But we're the
co-music directors.
And I also run the
ensemble Cantata Profana,
which is sort of our president
ensemble for Heartbeat.
DAN SCHLOSBERG: Dan Schlosberg,
the other co-music director.
And I also am a
pianist and composer.
PETER DOLCHIN: Great,
thank you, guys.
So I'm just going
to throw this out
for whoever wants
to answer it first,
but how did this all come about?
Not just Heartbeat Opera,
but your initial interest
in opera and in music,
and the passion around it,
and how did it blossom into the
formation of Heartbeat Opera?
ETHAN HEARD: Well, we're all
performers, or were originally.
Louisa Jacob and I actually sang
as kids in opera productions.
I was in DC, Louise in
Berlin, Jacob in New York.
Jacob was the star of New York
City Opera as a boy soprano.
So our opera roots are
deep and we met at Yale.
Louise and I were in
a drama school class
called Opera Practicum,
where we worked
with singers in the Yale opera
program for about eight weeks.
And it was this really
delicious workshop setting,
where we got to tackle
classic scenes in fresh
and sort of edgy ways.
And we wanted to bring that
kind of exploration to New York.
LOUISA PROSKE:
Yeah, and when you
go to the Met, which is
a beautiful and unique
experience, you're
often a football field
away from the singers.
And so what we experienced
in this class at Yale
was if you're four
feet, 10 feet,
two feet away from
the singer, there's
a different experience of
opera that you can have,
where you kind of start
to feel the vibrations
of these amazing voices on
your skin and in your bones.
And it really does
something physical to you
beyond the sort of intellectual
appreciation of opera
that we thought we could
bring to New York, that's
something unique that you
could never have at the Met.
PETER DOLCHIN: And Jen, I
know you joined the core group
a little bit after.
Will you just tell us a little
bit about how that happened?
JENNIFER NEWMAN: Sure, so
Heartbeat was formed, I think,
about a year before I joined on.
And they had had their first
time out with an audience
and creating for the first
time and realized, oh, this
is something we
want to keep doing.
We want more of this.
And at that point,
they were looking
for someone who could sort of
be more of a big picture person
to help usher along their
work as it moved forward.
And I was just coming back
from managing a larger company,
but in China, for about
a year and a half,
and was looking to get my hands
back in once I landed back
in New York.
And so I watched a little bit
of their work and was really
excited by the sort of
viscerality of the work,
the intimacy of the work,
and also that it wasn't--
that didn't feel stayed.
That it felt fresh, and so
that really attracted me
and so I said, absolutely, I
would like to join you guys.
So as a producer, I
think I look at work--
I come from a dance background,
but work in all manners of art,
and so I do look for that
sort of energy exchange.
And that's one of the
things that I really
liked about Harvey.
PETER DOLCHIN: Great.
Show of hands, how many people
have been to an opera before?
Wow, cultured group.
That's great.
DAN SCHLOSBERG: Sold.
PETER DOLCHIN: So
you were talking
a little bit about
how different this
is from the traditional
opera houses.
What do you sort
of try to preserve
that exists in the
traditional opera houses,
and where are you really
trying to change things up?
DAN SCHLOSBERG: I
guess I'll start.
This is our mission.
We like to say that we
have a healthy balance
of both reverence
and irreverence,
as you saw in some
of the photographs.
We often take
drastic steps to make
an opera that has been performed
the same way for hundreds
of years something of our own.
And for example,
two years ago, we
did Lucia di Lammermoor
and Louisa directed.
And we set the whole opera,
essentially, in a sanatorium,
and the leading character
was a crazy person.
There's a famous
mad scene in it.
And part of what I do is
create new orchestrations
of the opera.
We do not have the privilege
of a 80-person orchestra,
so I reduce the music.
And in this case, I added lots
of percussion and toy piano
to create this world
of her imagination
as she's kind of descending
into her craziness.
JACOB ASHWORTH: And
just those arrangements
that Dan does are something
that I think we found out
along the way, not having an
80-person orchestra is actually
one of the things we like
most about this company.
And it's something that
we started probably trying
to sort of approximate
that as best we could,
and then Dan with
this [AUDIO OUT]
said, well, what if we do
something completely different?
And that's kind of become
our MO since then--
trying to use the
means that we have
and the resources that we have
to do something that a bigger
company couldn't do.
ETHAN HEARD: I think there's
sort of the stereotype of opera
being for the elite, or the
super-educated, or the rich,
and Heartbeat's mission
is very much about making
it a popular art form again.
We love it as this
sort of coming together
of all performing arts--
dance, singing, drama, text.
And I like to imagine that
high schooler who has never
been to an opera before
when I'm creating a piece,
and thinking about,
OK, how do we make
this story accessible to
them, and also fun and sexy,
and bringing it sort of down off
of its pedestal a little bit?
So our drag show, we now
do an annual Halloween drag
extravaganza, and it's become
our kind of calling card.
We've done it two years
at National Sawdust, now,
in Williamsburg.
And we like to call it our kind
of gateway drug for someone,
for an opera virgin who
maybe has never felt
invited into that experience.
And we want it to be
not only a costume party
and a celebration, but
a sort of sneak peek
at what our work is all about.
PETER DOLCHIN: We
were certainly virgins
when we first checked it out.
So Heartbeat Opera
has been called,
by Alex Ross from "The New
Yorker," "a radical endeavor
for taking classic
operas and mixing it
with unconventional
orchestrations and stagings."
Tell us about the process you
go through to produce a show?
How do you go about selecting
the show, the talent,
the location, the set
design, the choreography,
the orchestration?
How much time does it take and
how much help do you guys have?
I know not very much, so--
LOUISA PROSKE: Well, I'll start
and then maybe somebody else
can take over.
So throughout the
year, it's really
the five of us with maybe two
or three other people running
the company.
But then come
February, March, when
we are gearing up
for our festival,
which this year is in the
first two weeks of May,
the company sort of grows
and we have over 70 people
working with us.
So suddenly, we become a
quite large organization.
But it all starts,
actually, in the summer
when we go on retreat together
and we put all of the pieces
that we love on the table.
And we sort to start a
debate about which one would
make a good Heartbeat show.
And there's a lot of things to
consider like the cast sizes,
whether it makes sense, or is
exciting to cut this piece down
to about 90 minutes, which
is how long our shows are?
PETER DOLCHIN: And
typical shows tend to be--
LOUISA PROSKE: I mean, opera
is often two and a half,
three, four hours--
five hours, if you're
talking Wagner, right?
So one of our signatures is
that we make the pieces shorter.
But we don't just-- it's
not just a reduction,
we actually often
rearrange the story lines
and sort of tell the
story through a new lens
that we conceive of so
that it feels modern
and now and relevant.
JACOB ASHWORTH: And I think when
we're choosing our repertoire,
we put a huge amount
of work all year long
into, basically, one drag
Halloween extravaganza and two
productions of
opera, so you have
to choose really wisely
what you're going
to put all of that effort into.
And as much as we do
love going to the Met
to see sort of
whatever's on, there's
plenty of operas that wouldn't
really take to an adaptation,
and you can't really
make them relevant today,
or the libretto is
just really poor.
And there is that in opera,
and so we choose wisely,
but it's also about sort
of taking these pieces that
might have been incredibly
exciting in their time,
and we feel maybe have
gotten a little stale.
But there's something at the
heart of them that we love.
We have we have to come to
these pieces out of love,
or else we would never be
able to put this much work
into them, and then
try to create something
over the course of the season,
over the course of the year
in along germination process.
ETHAN HEARD: More and
more, I'm realizing
that being a leader of
an arts organization
is all about team
building, and it's
about choosing great
people and helping
them do their best work.
So the next step in the
process once the shows have
been selected, is saying, OK,
who's going to design the set?
Who's doing the lighting?
Who are we casting?
And what's been really beautiful
about Heartbeat's growth
is that we have collaborators
that we return to
again and again.
So we have 10 core
associate artists now.
We have designers
that have worked
on pretty much every
piece we've done.
We've had singers who've
come back again and again.
So that team and
that community allows
us to work more quickly
and more deeply,
just out of trust
and out of love.
LOUISA PROSKE: One
of the challenges--
I mean, all of us are also
freelance artists in New York--
is that your life can
become very segmented.
You work for three
weeks here, you
work at this regional
theater for four weeks there.
You go and do a show on
the West Coast for a month.
And it's always with different
teams, with different casts,
with different artistic
directors, so it's a pretty--
in theater, you get very
intense very quickly in the room
because it's very personal
work, and then after four weeks,
it's over and you maybe
never see the people again.
So building a company,
for us, is really
to find that
continuity that's so
important in making
art and having history
with your collaborators.
And when you're doing the
fifth, sixth, seventh project
together, you just get
to a different plane.
PETER DOLCHIN: I think there
are similarities and parallels.
Clearly we're doing different
work here at Google,
but I think having
trust in a team
and collaborating and working
on different aspects of it
so that we all come
together, is very similar.
So it's just pointing
that out because I
think it's interesting that
we do something so very
different than you,
but there's still
a lot of core similarities and
paradigms that we both share.
When it comes to the work,
what's the most rewarding
and what's the most
challenging aspects of this?
JENNIFER NEWMAN: Huh--
who wants to take that?
We're going to be really
superficial on this answer--
no, just kidding.
I think that
rewarding is, for me,
always about the work being put
on stage and audiences getting
to see it.
I mean, that's the
exchange, right?
And I think in the
last couple of years,
we've developed a program
where every performance
we offer 10 free seats to
students in the New York area
who have never
seen opera before.
And so one of the biggest
rewards to us last year
was that we had
almost 100 students
at some point throughout
the season get to see opera,
and then they were
interviewed afterward.
And to hear their words after,
to say that, oh, I got it.
I thought I was
going to walk in here
and not get it, or
not feel anything.
And then they were able to sort
of recount their experience
through the opera, and that
was, for us, like, yes, we're
doing something right.
That's exactly what
we wanted to do.
So that was super
rewarding for us.
And personally, the
challenge is always time,
and I think you guys can
probably relate to that.
There's just never enough time.
Like we certainly are operating
in a space of non-human hours,
I think, at a certain point.
And we're just like,
there's more than 24 hours
in a day right?
Yeah, yeah.
I don't know.
That's for me.
DAN SCHLOSBERG: I just want
to-- we'll probably get to this
in a second, but for
on the reward side,
which is much easier
to talk about--
just to reach that
opera can have.
It's so easy to
just be caught up
in your insular New
York arts, especially
in the arts community.
But Ethan and I just went
on a trip to the Midwest
in our production
of "Fidelio," which
you'll hear an excerpt
from in a few minutes.
We're collaborating
with six prison choirs
and we were able to visit four
of them over the past week.
And just to see the
love and the humanity
that a project like this,
and singing in general,
can evoke and can
produce in people,
really reminds you of the
power of this kind of music.
PETER DOLCHIN: So
touching on that,
what inspired you to select
"Don Giovanni" and "Fidelio"
for the upcoming
spring festivals,
and where and when are
they taking place--
a little plug?
LOUISA PROSKE: Do
you want to talk--
JACOB ASHWORTH:
Sure, so we knew we
chose these for so many reasons,
but "Fidelio" is particularly,
as Dan has said,
we're setting it--
I'll let Ethan talk about
it a little bit more,
he's directing it.
But we're setting in
very current situation
that's very relevant.
And the "Don Giovanni" is one
of the richest pieces of music
that there is.
And we felt like we're
here, we're at season four.
We're ready to take
this on and to try
to tackle this
piece which probably
has the most complicated sort
of texture of characters,
and especially sexuality,
which is just--
there's characters
in this opera that
have become the archetypes
that we now refer to,
but they originated here.
It's the best crucible for all
of these different characters.
And so those two as a pairing
sort of made sense to us.
They're both from this
sort of similar time,
revolutionary ideas
in both of them
that seem to be coming
back to us now in 2018,
and newly relevant.
PETER DOLCHIN: And
when and where?
JACOB ASHWORTH: Oh, go for it.
ETHAN HEARD: Do you want to
say more about "Don Giovanni"?
LOUISA PROSKE: Yeah,
I mean, I would
say is that maybe something
we haven't really stressed
is that Ethan and I, our roots
are in music because were
both child performers
in opera, but we're
trained theater directors.
We both went to the
Yale School of Drama
and we really learned all
about directing actors.
And so we bring that
passion and meticulousness
of working with performers
to opera, where often,
singers are treated
more like musicians.
They go on stage and they sing,
but there's not necessarily
that sort of preciseness
of the acting vocabulary
that you would bring to theater,
and we merge those two things.
And for me, Mozart is just
one of the best writers
of character and
psychology, and so diving
into these seven people
in "Don Giovanni"
is just such a
treat as a director
because there's so
much to draw on.
ETHAN HEARD: Just to talk a
little bit about "Fidelio,"
it's Beethoven's
one opera, and it's
about a woman who disguises
herself and infiltrates
the prison where she believes
her husband is wrongfully
incarcerated.
So I had come across
this opera in grad school
and was trying to
choose something
to do in 2018 that really
had something powerful to say
about our moment.
And here we go--
I mean, I started
immediately imagining what
if it was an
American story today?
What if we saw a lot of
people of color in the cast?
What if this is a Black Lives
Matter activist, actually,
who has been
wrongfully detained?
His wife is trying
desperately to find him,
trying to seek
pro-bono legal advice,
being sort of turned down.
And here is this
corrupt white warden
who's running this prison and
trying to silence his opponent.
So it also came to mind, here
we had this famous prisoners
chorus that occurs in
the middle of the opera,
how are we going to do that?
In the past, Heartbeat has
sort of avoided choruses.
We've kept the casts much
more focused and small.
But Dan brought up that he
knew a prison choir director
in Minnesota.
And we reached out to her,
and Amanda then connected
us with, I guess, three
other prison choir
directors across the Midwest.
And suddenly, we had six
amazing choirs-- male, female,
and mixed choirs--
committed to
collaborating with us.
So we're capturing
audio recordings
of them singing a new four-part
arrangement that Dan did.
And then we're also--
we just this past week,
videoed their
rehearsals, and we'll
be creating an
almost montage music
video of the real
incarcerated singers
to be shown in the
middle of the production.
LOUISA PROSKE: So
the when and the
where is, if you
look on your seats,
you have the flyers
for the festival.
It runs from March--
sorry, May 2nd through 13th.
There are six performances
of each opera.
And there's actually
one day where
you can see both operas in
one day, which would make you
probably one of the very
few people in history
to have seen "Fidelio" and
"Don Giovanni" on the same day,
so you can brag about
that for your whole life.
And yeah, it's very easy
to buy tickets online
or over the phone.
PETER DOLCHIN: Fantastic.
DAN SCHLOSBERG: Oh, and where?
LOUISA PROSKE: Oh, it's
at Baruch Performing Arts
Center, which is on 27th and
Lexington, so not too far.
PETER DOLCHIN: No.
Are there any questions
from anyone in the room?
JENNIFER NEWMAN: There
are more post-graduates
that don't have the [INAUDIBLE]
PETER DOLCHIN: OK.
AUDIENCE: Is there a mic?
PETER DOLCHIN: There is.
There's a mic right in the back.
AUDIENCE: Hey, y'all.
My question was around--
for most operas being in
non-English, and where--
I'm sorry.
I still have to start over.
Hello?
No?
OK, I don't think it's on.
So my question is
around just language
and the role it plays
in kind of-- as you
try make opera more accessible.
How do you approach the
language and telling the story,
and having people kind of--
I mean, A, I don't know.
Are you translating?
Are you doing them in English?
Are you doing them in Italian,
depending on the language
that it was written in?
How do you approach
language and making
that a part of-- for
English-speaking people,
have that be part of
feeling that opera
and being a part of it?
PETER DOLCHIN: Great question.
LOUISA PROSKE: Yeah, we're
not super dogmatic about that.
So sometimes when we feel it's
right, we translate the text.
So when we did "Daphnis
et Chloé" three years ago,
which is an Offenbach operetta
and it's very populist,
sort of almost
borderline musical,
we felt like people just have
to understand immediately where
the jokes land and where
the punch lines are.
So we translated
it into English.
There are other operas
like Puccini and Bizet
where the sound of
the words is really
important to the way
the music is structured,
so it becomes a little more
difficult to translate,
so then we often do supertitles.
But in the case of
"Fidelio" or "Carmen,"
for example, where it's a mixed
opera with music and dialogues,
we always translate
the dialogues.
Maybe you want to
speak more about--
ETHAN HEARD: Yeah, and this
production of "Fidelio"
is the first time we hired a
playwright to really re-imagine
the dialogue.
So some of our--
in adapting the
story, we've actually
taken the opportunity, taken the
liberty of just re-conceiving
what a dialogue
needs to accomplish,
and making that a really
contemporary American sound.
JACOB ASHWORTH: I would also
say it's a great question
and something that we
do think about a lot,
especially when we
do our drag shows,
which there's so much more
going on in the design,
that it's a little bit harder
to imagine somebody looking up
at subtitles any
time there's somebody
in a fabulous dress that's just
entered and started singing.
And so we try, there, to either
use as much angle as possible,
or pick things where we feel
like we can make a design
and direction
around it, such that
you don't need a translation.
You know exactly
what they're doing
and we can somehow show it
to you in a different way.
But we are, in general,
trying to make opera more
closer to the sort of
populist roots that it has.
And opera has,
over the centuries,
gone back and forth
between being a little more
popular and a little more
aristocratic, and a little more
popular.
And you notice popular's
the top of the crest for me.
But I mean, I'll go ahead and
say here, at Talks at Google,
that my prediction is
that in about 50 years,
we're back to translating
everything and putting
everything in the vernacular,
and we're singing everything
in English the way that people
did only 70, 80 years ago
when people wanted
populist opera,
but didn't have subtitles yet,
didn't have the technology.
There was a period
where that happened.
And so we're always
talking about it.
PETER DOLCHIN: Great, so
before we start losing people,
there are two more
performances, so we want
to save some time for that.
Are there any other questions?
There's one more question.
AUDIENCE: Super quick one-- so
I remember back in high school,
directing a one-act play and
sending in my $50 to Samuel
French for the royalties.
And so I'm thinking for
small comp-- are royalties
a thing in opera, and do they
prevent you from doing things
that you want to do as
a very small company?
LOUISA PROSKE: Well,
almost everything we do
has is beyond royalties, so
it's in the public domain, which
is part of the great joy of then
being able to cut it up and use
it however you want.
JACOB ASHWORTH: But
it does restrict us
from doing anything that
was written 10 years ago,
or 20 years ago without
very explicit permission.
Because the thing that we
would struggle with the most
is if we said you know to
John Adams or somebody,
we'd like to do
your opera but we'd
like to do it for six
clarinets, are you OK with that?
And most likely, no--
although, actually,
he might, he might.
But if you do things that
are over 75 or 90 years old,
depending on the
country, you get out
of most of that trouble.
But it is a consideration, yes.
PETER DOLCHIN: Thanks.
So before we jump
into the performances,
I just want to thank you
for taking the time to come.
You guys are doing cutting edge,
really cultural, unique things
in society, and in New
York, specifically.
And I just hope that this
helped build that fan base,
so thank you.
ETHAN HEARD: Thank
you for having us.
LOUISA PROSKE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PETER DOLCHIN: So
we'll head off.
While we're setting up
for the performances,
we're going to have another
video of their fall--
of the spring festival.
So will you
introduce what it is?
LOUISA PROSKE: Oh, it's going
to be "Butterfly" and "Carmen,"
which were our last spring
productions a year ago, yes.
PETER DOLCHIN:
Awesome, thank you.
[OPERATIC MUSIC]
LOUISA PROSKE: So
now you're going
to hear two more selections from
our upcoming spring festival,
actually, first, an
aria from "Don Giovanni"
and then an aria from "Fidelio."
So this aria from
"Don Giovanni,"
it's the character Zerlina,
who is an expert with men.
And she just came back
from sort of trying
to seduce this very, very
beautiful nobleman called
Don Giovanni, and being
interrupted in it.
And so now she's back
with her husband,
who is just furious that he
left her on their wedding day
to go with this other man.
So she is sort of dealing
with his anger by saying,
go ahead, beat me.
Beat me up if you want to.
You can scratch my eyes.
You can tear my hair.
But afterwards, we'll
make peace again.
[MUSIC - SAMARIE ALICIEA, ARIA
FROM "DON GIOVANNI"]
[APPLAUSE]
ETHAN HEARD: Our next and
final selection is from
"Fidelio.'" So Leah has just
overheard the corrupt warden
making plans to murder her
husband who is being wrongfully
kept in solitary confinement.
So she starts with just
an explosion of rage.
She goes to a very
despairing place.
And then by the end
of the aria, she's
finding strength and
hope again that she
will be able to save him--
Kelly Griffin.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - KELLY GRIFFIN, ARIA
FROM "FIDELIO"]
[APPLAUSE]